INTRO:
Recently, you may have heard that Russia may
be loosening restrictions on piracy in an
effort to combat all of the tech sanctions
that have been placed on their citizens.
This makes sense as basically every tech and
media company you can think of has sanctioned
Russia so in order to continue being productive
and get some entertainment, Russia basically
has to turn to piracy.
But, something that you may not have expected
though is that there are rumors and speculation
floating around that Biden may not only loosen
restrictions surrounding piracy, but he may
legalize piracy altogether in America with
an upcoming executive order.
Ever since these rumors surfaced, pirates
from around the world have rejoiced as this
move could spark an international copyright
revolution.
In the meantime, production studios have been
mortified as they struggle to understand how
the billions they spent on lobbying failed
to prevent this.
So, here’s the reasoning behind why Biden
may be introducing this legislation, the details
about what it may include, and its potential
short and long-term repercussions.
DEFLATION CRISIS:
Starting with the reasoning for such a move,
we have the deflation crisis.
As you guys know, over the past year, deflation
has gone through the roof.
Now, this may be confusing at first given
that CPI readings would suggest the exact
opposite.
For example, the most recent CPI reading suggested
an inflation rate of 7.9% which is the highest
we’ve seen in 4 decades.
Also, let’s not forget that gas prices are
literally $7 a gallon in some parts of the
country.
But, as Jerome has been preaching from the
start, this slight increase in prices is just
transitory.
So, gas prices should stabilize at $6.50 any
day now.
In the meantime, the commodities of our era
have been deflating faster than ever before.
Take Apple for example.
People often complain about how expensive
Apple products have become as many of their
products cost well over a $1000.
They even sell a monitor stand for $1000.
But, the thing that people forget to consider
is that Apple has yet to raise prices on any
of these products despite rampant inflation.
A $1000 in 2019 is equivalent to $1109 today,
yet Apple still only charges a $1000 for the
stand.
This means that the Pro stand has dropped
in price by roughly 10%.
Now, 10% may not sound like much, but when
you’re talking about $50,000 Mac Pro, you’re
actually getting a $5000 discount.
So, as Cathie Wood was suggesting, the real
fear is not inflation but actually deflation.
But what does deflation have to do with piracy?
Well, during a deflation crisis, cash is king
and unfortunately, most millennials have on
cash.
This isn’t all that surprising given that
the average millennial would rather water
their plants than handle finances, but it
does pose a serious problem.
As baby boomers retire and cut back on spending,
millennials are becoming the workhorse of
the economy.
But given that most of them are broke, we’ll
see less capital flowing into dogecoin, Shiba
Inu, Floki Inu, and the leading NFTs.
So, Biden’s potential executive order is
simply attempting to curb this decline.
If millennials no longer have to pay for their
17 media and entertainment subscriptions every
month, they can actually save a substantial
amount of money.
Now, it’s not like they’re gonna save
this for retirement, but proponents of this
executive order are hoping that they turn
around and spend this money on something more
lucrative.
You see, media companies aren’t the most
lucrative businesses.
Disney, for example, hasn’t been able to
crack a 5% net margin since the pandemic started.
Meanwhile, Starbucks has been holding strong
at a 15% net margin which is 3 times higher.
So, if millennials spend more money at Starbucks
instead of paying for media, which is probably
where they’ll spend it, corporate America
as a whole can generate more profits.
Corporate America can then turn around and
invest this extra money into real assets such
as stocks, real estate, bonds, and commodities
like the Mac Pro which will hopefully curb
the impacts of the deflation crisis.
EXECUTIVE ORDER #02496:
Now that we’ve discussed the reasoning behind
this potential executive order, let’s delve
into the meat of the legislation itself.
The first rumors of such a move surfaced from
the official TFES Twitter account at 7:37
AM.
They tweeted quote, “Watch out for Biden’s
potential Executive Order #02496.
Piracy may be legalized very soon.”
At first, people didn’t really know what
this meant, but soon enough, more and more
tweets started to surface.
Tony Stark, for example, tweeted “Haha.
Good thing I called it with Endgame years
ago.”
Shortly after, Elon Musk tweeted, “Does
this mean no more Iron Man cameos?”
Meanwhile, Facebook tweeted, “Too bad the
movie industry didn’t embrace the data collection
model.”
All of these cryptic tweets were still quite
confusing to put together, but eventually,
we saw a new Wikipedia page pop up that gave
details into the executive order.
The Wikipedia page describes the deflation
threat that’s looming over the United States
and how Biden has little choice but to pass
this executive order.
If this executive order were to pass, piracy
of all movies, games, software, and music
would become perfectly legal within the United
States.
On top of this, all convicted pirates will
be cleared of all charges and released from
prison.
Now, you may be wondering, if no one is paying
for media, then no production company will
want to produce any content right?
Well, that’s what everyone thought at first
including Tony Stark, but fortunately, a powerful
individual has stepped up to the plate.
The executive order outlines that any and
all production activities will be personally
funded by Jerome’s money printer.
Jerome figured that with deflation getting
out of hand, printing some extra cash can’t
hurt.
Also, production costs amongst even the biggest
production studios are peanuts for Jerome.
Disney, for example, was planning on spending
$33 billion on content in 2022.
For Jerome, $33 billion is just a day of printing
if that, so it doesn’t look like production
studios will run into any funding issues anytime
soon.
One thing to note though is that Jerome will
only cover production costs and that he won’t
be paying for profits.
So, these production studios still have to
figure out how to monetize their viewers to
generate profits, but moving forward they’ll
never have to worry about recouping production
costs.
It’s just a matter of how much profits can
they generate.
REPERCUSSIONS:
With such a game-changing piece of legislation,
there’s no doubt that we’ll see massive
short-term and long-term repercussions.
One of the first moves we’ve seen production
companies take is initiating massive bidding
wars for all of the most popular piracy sites.
Now, if this legislation passes, Netflix,
Disney, Hulu, and all the other popular streaming
platforms will have download links to all
of their content on their websites themselves.
But, it seems like a lot of people prefer
to use the classic piracy sites over these
offerings, hence the bidding war.
KickAssTorrents for example was recently acquired
by an undisclosed party for $32 billion.
Meanwhile, the Pirate Bay has apparently received
dozens of private offers with the highest
offer clocking in at over $100 billion.
This is quite ironic given that just a few
hours ago, acquiring any one of these sites
would’ve been unthinkable given the insane
liabilities that each of them carries.
Also, we should note that the executive order
hasn’t even been passed yet.
So, these bidders are taking quite a risk
by prematurely acquiring these sites, but
I guess they can afford it.
Given the size of the offers, I think it’s
likely that the offer is either from Netflix
or Disney, but then again, it could just as
easily be from Google or Facebook as well
given that this is the perfect opportunity
to capitalize on the trend towards piracy.
While Artem Vaulin, KickAssTorrents founder,
quickly agreed to sell KickAssTorrents, the
same cannot be said about the Pirate Bay’s
Founders.
For them, running the Pirate Bay is less about
making money and more about principle.
One of the Pirate Bay’s co-founders, Frederick
Neij has literally said that spending time
in prison was well worth for the Pirate Bay.
So, it’s not surprising that they weren’t
enticed to sell out to big tech.
Not to mention, they can likely make a lot
more money if they simply went public which
seems to be the plan.
Gottfrid Svartholm tweeted, “Mark your calendars.
The Pirate Bay may have an IPO on April 20.”
If this actually does end up taking place,
the Pirate Bay will evolve into being one
of the largest companies in the world basically
overnight.
Also, given that the three co-founders currently
own all the equity in the company, they’ll
each likely become multi-deca billionaires.
So, the future is looking pretty bright for
both production companies and piracy sites
alike, but only time will tell who will become
the biggest pirate.
PUBLIC RESPONSE:
In terms of the response to this legislation,
companies seem to be all over the place.
Adobe, for example, tweeted “Eh, it’s
not like it makes a difference to us anyway.”
Meanwhile, Disney has promised a full-on press
meeting to hash out their plan moving forward.
If they’re able to acquire a large piracy
site like The Pirate Bay, it’s likely that
Disney will shift to displaying ads and collecting
data similar to Google and Facebook.
They’ll probably also continue to offer
their movies in theaters for a fee if people
are interested.
As for the public, most pirates don’t really
care all that much.
The biggest upside for them is that they no
longer have to pay for a VPN, but then again
if Disney and Netflix start to collect data
through piracy sites, it’s probably best
to use a VPN anyway.
So, it doesn’t really make a difference
to most pirates.
Meanwhile, we’ve seen a lot of piracy noobs
navigating to rip-off sites of the Pirate
Bay, downloading various viruses, and falling
for the stupidest of scams.
It’s probably best if these guys stick to
paying for their media until companies come
out with their own download portals.
In terms of countrywide responses, Russia
has perceived this as a challenge.
After all, they were the first world power
to loosen restrictions on piracy.
In an effort to stay one step ahead of the
US, it’s expected that Putin will announce
that Russia will not only allow for the piracy
of media but also the piracy of intellectual
property.
In other words, all patents and trademarks
will become void meaning that anyone can copy,
produce and sell anything.
Such a policy seems too woke to be adopted
by the US right now, but if the US enters
a piracy war with Russia, we may see similar
policies surfacing very soon.
But we’ll just have to wait and see.
Do you guys support this executive order?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you wish Jerome’s money
printer could subsidize your operations.
And of course, consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more questions
illogically conspired.